Wow.
Applause at the beginning.
Thanks, Hunter.
So that person who
just wooed, I just
want to shout out,
that's Hunter Glands.
He's also at Cal Poly.
We're both faculty.
And he helped me with
this project, is involved
in the coding, and everything.
We decided not to switch off
talking in a short session.
But if you have
questions, et cetera,
you can ask him as well.
So right there, making noises.
OK.
So in this talk, I
just want to tell you
about what I've done
in the really, really
intro-level classes.
So the way I'm going to
structure this-- basically,
there's a lot of
window dressing.
I want to give you some
background on what courses
we have at Cal Poly, the
advantages and challenges
of using R in some of
these classes, which I'm
sure many of you
are familiar with,
and then what my lab
assignments look like,
what are the students
being asked to do.
And then the reason
for the hamburger--
apart from it being
mid-afternoon and lunch has
worn off--
is that the meat of this
talk is these pre-lab
exercises that Hunter
and I have built
in Shiny that have kind
of helped us introduce R
to beginners.
And then, I don't know,
I've got some-- is that OK?
Some student
outcome information.
I've surveyed the
students, so hopefully you
think lettuce is also
important to hamburgers.
And oh, I forgot that
I have a clicker.
I'm not used to this fanciness.
Yeah.
So and then some take-home
messages, advice if any of you
are teaching such classes.
So at Cal Poly, the
courses using R--
we do have a dedicated R class,
so that one you would hope
involves R in some way.
But we also have a lot
of upper-level classes,
and those will
involve some coding
in order to get the
concepts across, et cetera.
Most of the professors
seem to favor R,
although it's up to
our decision there.
But then we also have these
service-level classes,
is what we call the introductory
classes for non-majors.
And these are the
classes where there's
no stat or CS background.
There's no prerequisites
of any kind.
And so everyone agrees
that these students should
see software in some
way, but typically people
are using applets.
There's some debate over
whether we should use R or use
something-- an applet,
or jump, or Minitab--
some of these easier
point-and-click approaches.
That's debatable.
There's no opposition
to using R as the tool,
but what is really
kind of unpopular
is that students in these
classes should code,
because these are not
stat or CS majors.
For my class, they're
bio majors, viticulture,
food science, animal
science, things like that.
So this is the class
I want to talk about,
is the service-level
class that I teach.
And I do think there's a lot
of advantages to introducing
coding in this class.
You may or may
not agree with me.
Pedagogically, I
think that thinking
through things with code forces
them to not just memorize
steps.
What are the steps of a
hypothesis test, or a t-test?
Same thing.
Linear regression, et cetera.
They have to plan ahead,
plan their output,
and not memorize formulas.
Conceptually, I think
we live in an age
where data is all digital.
And so thinking of data
as a digital object,
and how do people
interact with it,
it's a good way to
kind of interface
with how this is being
done in the real world,
and to think of
data as information,
and not a list of numbers
that's handed to you on an exam.
And then practically speaking,
of course, not all of them
are going to be data
scientists or creators.
But they do need
to understand how
it's done in the real world.
I don't know why we are still
using these t tables here
and normal z tables.
Nobody uses that
in the real world.
We're all just going
to use pnorm, qnorm,
or our language of choice, if
this were not an R conference.
It makes no sense to be using
things in class that are never,
ever, ever going to be
encountered in the real world.
So this is my opinion,
anyway, that I
think these students should
benefit from seeing code.
It's not always easy, though.
I keep forgetting.
You know, we don't
have these at Cal Poly.
It's a state school.
[LAUGHTER]
Some of the challenges
that I've encountered
with these new students--
logistically, I went
in the first time
I used R in this class.
I was gung ho.
I had put so much thought
into how to make this gentle,
and introduce them to coding.
And what I instead dealt
with for the whole class is,
where is my downloads folder?
[LAUGHTER]
These kids are 17 to 23.
I thought they'd grown up with
computers, and it was natural.
But I've learned there's
kind of a sweet spot
in between the people that
are frightened of computers,
and the people
that are frightened
of downloads folders.
So that was a challenge.
There's ways around
it, and I don't
want to dwell on this too much.
This is very important
to the class,
but it's not really
my contribution,
so there's many better people
than I to speak of this.
But I just want to mention,
using cloud servers has really
helped in this class.
RStudio Cloud is awesome.
Amazon Web Services--
you can set up
your own home cloud, which is
what we've done at Cal Poly.
And then using notebooks
to feed them code--
that helps-- or to call
your own scripts, et cetera.
GitHub Classroom is really cool.
I've just gotten
started with that.
That's a nice way to just
package everything off
to these students.
And then they use this package
that's kind of idiot-proof,
as they say.
So these things can help.
I would just point
you to those if you're
interested in using R for
people that are frightened
of downloads folders.
But anyway, the other
challenges that I
run into, besides those
logistics, are pedagogical.
I want to involve
coding in my teaching,
but I'm not teaching coding.
I'm teaching statistics,
and I'm teaching
concepts of statistics.
And so how do I do that without
ending up just teaching coding?
And what I get in
feedback a lot is,
we spent all this time learning
R, and it wasn't on the exam.
I did put R output that they
have to read on the exam,
but they don't
have to write code,
there's no coding
questions, and so forth.
So this is a big question, of
how to synthesize those ideas.
And then these
students are mostly
students who are forced to take
stat, don't want to take stat,
they don't think they like math.
And so it just adds
one more thing for them
to be scared about
in this intro class.
So I did a survey.
I did some extensive
surveys of my class
this fall that ended
just in December.
And this is what the
students had to say.
I had the question, I feel
nervous about my ability
to complete the lab assignment.
And over the first three
lab assignments here,
they're pretty nervous.
More than half of
them are saying
that they strongly
agree or agree
that they're nervous about it.
And it wasn't really
getting better, actually,
across the assignments.
So this is something
they find daunting,
and I will readily admit that,
that it's a challenge for them.
So let me tell you
what these assignments
that are so terrifying
that I'm using in my class.
When I first started out--
OK, so here's an example
of a data set that I use.
I'm sure many of
you have seen it.
It's the Wine dataset.
We've got a whole bunch of
chemical measures of wine,
and then we've got this measure
at the bottom-- quality--
that's going to say if
it's a good or a bad wine,
as rated by experts.
So the idea is, what
different chemical properties
does the wine have
to be a good wine?
And so in my first version
of these labs-- and these
are just snippets from the labs.
They're obviously much longer
and formatted differently.
But I just give them
this t-test code,
and I ask them
questions about it.
And their job is to
look at that output
and interpret it correctly.
So it's not really coding.
It's reading output,
but it's not coding.
And then the next version
was, reproduce my process.
So first I would do the same
thing-- ask them something,
give them that code.
And then I'd say--
well, here what I
asked them about was pH level.
Does the pH level of the
wine matter to the quality?
And then I said,
now suppose I've
made some claim about density.
Can you back that claim up?
And all they're going to do is
copy, paste, and write density
where pH is.
Or ideally that's what
they're going to do.
You'd be surprised the number of
different things they would do,
such as writing t.test.density--
weird stuff like that, because
they're so new to this.
I have a clicker.
Version 3 is where I really
think my students are
being statisticians.
This is where I have not
given them almost anything.
I have said, choose
three chemical attributes
of the wine.
Make me some plots.
Do some t-tests.
This is what their lab
assignment literally
looked like on this, and this
is the third lab assignment.
So this is week four.
I don't do one the first
week of a 10-week course.
So this is cool, right?
I think it's really cool that
non-majors can handle this,
and they really can.
But how do I get them
there, is the question,
without having given
them anything right here
to work with.
So what we came up with, this
intermediate transition tool,
is these pre-lab
exercises in Shiny.
And so where this
idea came from was
at ICOTS, the conference on
teaching statistics in Japan
last summer, Hunter and
I went to two talks.
I think there's a
rule that you have
to quote Hadley if you're going
to talk at this conference.
That's what I heard.
But really, there were
these two talks back to back
that really influenced us.
The main one was
Amelia McNamara saying,
"We need a bridge between"--
there's learning statistics.
Those are applets.
And there's doing statistics.
That's being a true
programmer or coder.
And there's not really a
bridge in between these things
right now.
And this kind of
matched a vision
that I've had for a long
time floating in my brain.
And then Hadley backing up
that not all statisticians need
to be coders, but if you're
not interacting with code,
are you really doing statistics?
I think the challenges
and the advantages
pedagogically-- they all pale
in comparison to the fact
that, if we're offering
to teach statistics
and we don't teach them to think
about it as a digital process,
we are not teaching
them statistics.
That's my opinion.
I'm sure many will disagree, but
I would love to argue with you.
[LAUGHTER]
So that's the idea, so
that's where this came from.
So Hunter and I--
we went upstairs
at this conference,
and we sat down amongst all the
Japanese business people having
lunch, and we coded
for a couple hours,
and then spent the
whole summer continuing
to develop these things.
So the idea is the principles
behind these tools.
We figured they should
have immediate results.
What's nice about
applets is the students
go very quickly to
seeing output that
is exciting and interpretable.
So we wanted to maintain
that, to kind of immediately
see the process.
But then we wanted
to require them
to be generating
the queries, to not
be selecting from a drop-down
menu or clicking a checkbox
or so forth, as a
real coder would.
And we also wanted to make
really clear what's built
into R versus what
they're choosing,
because this is
not an R-specific--
I'm not trying to
teach them R. So I
want them to be able
to interact, then,
with another language
and understand,
we have to think about
what variables we're using,
even if the function
to make a box plot
or whatever has
a different name.
And then I really wanted to
link the concepts and questions
from lecture--
the big ideas-- to what was
happening with the code.
So I want to do a demo here.
And I've got a
backup plan, but I
think these are working
fine on shinyapps.io.
So I'll have these
links at the end.
I've got three of these
hosted on shinyapps.io
if you want to demo them.
For the class, we
hosted them separately
because shinyapps
would get pummeled
and I would not be able to
handle it on my free account.
But these ones are here, if
you guys want to try them.
So the idea here is this was
their first lab exercise.
It's built on learnr, so someone
asked a question earlier--
a really nice package
for this kind of thing.
And the key here is that
what we're going to do
is, we have the Titanic data
set for all of these exercises,
and they have to
choose the variables.
So let's say we want
to look at gender,
and then we want to
see who survived.
There we go.
And so what this does,
and kind of the key point,
is it fills in that
code line there.
Is that OK?
I can zoom in a
little bit there.
So that line of code--
they're seeing the
blue, is the thing
that is a name that was chosen.
But I chose it.
They didn't input it just now.
And the red is the stuff
that they just selected,
and the rest of it
is just the syntax
of this particular
coding language.
And so then we see, OK,
they used facet_grid.
And you can kind of
get an idea what's
going on, but not so great.
So we can go down to stacked
bar charts, things like that,
make different choices.
They can see the
output immediately,
and decide which of those plots
answers their question better.
Which one is going to show
you that men tended to die,
and women tended to
survive on the Titanic?
And so additionally, we
have this idea of tying it
to the concepts in class.
So here's the
exercise for t-tests
where we can say, all right.
I'd like to make claims
about the age on Titanic--
the age of the passengers.
And under the
null, let's say 30.
And let's say we're
interested in testing
whether the average age was
less than 30 for some reason.
And so we can see this
in words that they've
been seeing in class.
The hypothesis is
that the true mean
is equal to 30,
versus less than 30.
We can see this in code,
again with the blue and red.
And then we can see the output
that they have to interpret.
And learnr is nice.
It's got a good interface
for including some questions.
We can say, oh, look, what
sample mean did I observe?
Well that was 29.557.
There we go.
And it'll tell them right away
they got it right, so they're
able to check and make sure that
they've gotten the output that
was expected.
And then the last one
I want to show you,
just to tie all these
principles together,
is the normal random
variables in general.
So we could say
something like, let's say
we have a normal random
variable with a mean of 67
and a standard deviation of 3,
and I'm interested in the area
below 60.
So again, I'm tying
this to the way
they've seen it
in class, which is
this notation of
normally distributed
and what's the probability.
And then we can see
the code, the result,
and then I made these
little illustrations just
so they can see
what's going on, what
the picture looks like there.
So all these things that they
see typically in lecture,
all in one place, and being
dynamically generated thanks
to the magic of Shiny, and the
coding that Hunter and I have
done, I suppose.
So those are the exercises.
There we go.
And so let me tell you what
happened when I finally
used these.
So I started these
out on my summer class
with only 18 students,
and used them
with 108 students this fall.
The first thing is students
definitely recognize
that R is applicable.
This question says, the
in-class lab activity
helped me understand how
statistical analyses are
conducted in the real world.
They overwhelmingly agree,
or at least feel neutrally
about that.
No one is arguing with that.
They recognize the
value to themselves.
This one says, the
in-class activities
help me understand the concepts
from the week's material.
And you can see they,
over time, started to see
more how this was helping them.
I don't know if that
was a progression
as they got more comfortable, or
if maybe that third lab, which
had to do with the t-tests,
was particularly helpful.
One way or the other, I
like that that was positive,
and also that it improved
over these three labs
that I surveyed heavily on.
I really like this one.
I asked, I feel proud
of the work I produced
on the assignment,
the assignment
being the actual data
analysis, not these exercises.
And they feel very proud of it.
Almost none of them
feel un-proud of it.
And most of them
were kind of excited.
And it was fun, during
these exercises,
to watch them hit knit on
their file and go, oh my gosh.
It worked.
This is cool, and
explore this data.
That was very rewarding
for me, anyway.
I surveyed them pretty heavily
on the skills they gained.
This one, they were asked
to agree or disagree
or whatever with, I feel
confident in my ability
to read read and
interpret a bar plot.
And that one, it looks
like the lab helped.
So I surveyed them before
anything, after the exercise,
and then after the assignment
itself-- the full analysis.
And there seems to be some
improvement happening.
I was hoping to find some
improvement over concepts,
and I didn't actually
really find that.
Mostly anything that was about
identifying aspects of data,
or describing
aspects of data, they
did not self-report improving.
Although anecdotally, I do
actually feel that they did.
And then small
improvements for anything
to do with creating
or analyzing plots,
and a little bit to do
with calculating things.
So some feedback.
I'm hanging myself out
to dry here reading
one of my least
favorite sentences
that I've ever received.
But in summer,
one of my students
described these as a,
"complete, unorganized,
catastrophic mess."
I was having a lot of trouble
figuring out how to host them.
shinyapps couldn't
handle my students,
and I had to relearn Unix
to host them elsewhere.
So there was some
technical difficulties.
I tried it on that class because
there was only 18 of them,
so I could help them out.
But for the 108 in this past
fall, it went very smoothly.
And here's three
of the comments.
People are saying
that they thought
these labs were helpful.
There were some slightly
negative comments,
but nothing like this one.
They were more, I
don't understand why we
did it, instead of, I hated it.
So that was encouraging.
And lastly, I didn't survey
heavily my previous classes.
I didn't know I was going to
be experimenting like this.
But in winter 2018, I
also had three sections
about the same time,
same number of students.
Homework was pretty
much identical.
I didn't tweak it too much
between winter and fall.
And the lab material
was the same--
the same data sets
and questions--
but it was split for the fall
into this pre-lab and lab
format.
And so I asked
them two questions.
Halfway through the
quarter, I asked them
how much the homework
assignments helped,
and how much the lab
assignments helped.
And what we found
was not a huge change
in the homework from winter
to fall, which you'd expect.
It's the same homework.
But the lab assignments,
if you see here--
oh, I keep forgetting
this exists.
These lab assignments
here in the winter,
like 3/4 of my class
hated them, or didn't
think they were useful.
And in the fall,
most of the class
did think they were useful,
or at least felt neutral.
So I think that is
maybe attributable
to these exercises.
So just some take-home
messages, what worked well.
I liked that the students
could analyze data
from scratch themselves.
Anecdotally, I really think the
students ended up better off
in the winter class
or the fall class.
I like seeing them get
excited about results.
What didn't work?
Well, first of all,
these exercises--
we banged them out.
We are not developers.
We're trying to be.
We're getting there.
But we're not.
I'm going to hang
myself out to dry again.
This is what it
looks like when I
have to output both
the strings of code,
and also evaluate that code.
In particular, I'm just going to
really hang myself out to dry.
A lot of people I know
will get mad at me
for that-- eval(parse).
Ugh.
I know it's a crime, but I
don't know what else to do.
And I wanted to do
something, and something
is better than nothing.
So there we are.
Sorry, Dave Robinson.
[LAUGHTER]
And so apart from
that-- and this
is why I'm sharing it with you.
One reason is in the
hopes that there's
people out there who
might want to help
me make this more of a usable,
sharable, manageable tool.
I think this idea of thinking
through code-- students tended
to type their variable
names for the new data
into the exercise, which
of course wouldn't run.
But then they would
copy paste, which
isn't quite what I was
hoping, but maybe it's OK.
And motivating the
students-- they really
were disturbed by
the fact that they
were spending class
time on something
that wasn't on the exam.
So my advice for you.
The growing pains are worth it.
That is a headache,
but it's worth it.
I think if you have an idea
for a teaching tool, build it.
It's not perfect.
Mine is ugly, but it's
cool and it helped.
And that these kids can
handle R. They really can.
They grew up with computers.
They can do more than
they think they can.
They can think about data.
They can do it, and so can
the people teaching them.
So I hope that more
interests classes will really
engage with coding instead of
just applets in the future.
That's my goal.
All right.
So the GitHub repository
there has all the material
for these exercises, if you to
use, or better yet, edit them.
Those three demos-- the
links are here, and then
contact info for me or Hunter.
And that's all I got.
[APPLAUSE]
We have time for one question.
Hi.
This is a great talk.
Thank you very much.
So a lot of times when
I hear these discussions
about computing and
statistics pedagogy,
they're along two veins.
One is, I think, kind of
what you're doing here,
which is using R and Shiny
in these kinds of tools
to improve the teaching
of classical topics.
And the other one is
to replace the teaching
of classical topics with more
computationally-based stuff,
like permutation testing,
bootstrap, stuff like that
right up front instead of
normal derivations of t-test,
things like that.
I was wondering if that
second component of it
is something you
and your colleagues
have discussed as
you're incorporating
more of this stuff into
the these earlier classes?
Yeah, totally.
So I think the question is
about using computing just
to reinforce things
like t-tests,
versus to introduce things
like permutation tests that
get the spirit of hypothesis
testing without the math
maybe necessary.
Yeah, that's a big discussion.
I think Beth Chance
teaches a class
fully on simulation
permutation tests and none
of the other stuff.
For me, I kind of
believe in teaching
the classical concepts, because
they are going to see that.
Even if they never
do that, they're
going to read papers
in their fields,
and it's probably going
to have a t-score.
They should know what that is.
And so mostly I've been using
it to reinforce those concepts,
but also I do feel
really strongly about
don't do something in a class
that is never, ever going
to happen in the real world.
So as maybe those
things go away,
then it would make more sense
to emphasize the other stuff.
Yeah.